all right and we are love the last word
with Lorca Dido and I bought this brush
at the campfire Friday seems like we got
a special guess what's going to e yeah
you know it's um it's been Guardian
games we had to bring one of the future
to be victors in here so I'm gonna let
you introduce our guest though but yeah
if you guys are a fan of any people
invest the community you guys should
know this man if you don't we're gonna
introduce you to him right now
actly welcome to the last word episode
number 102 the glorious Friday we're
back in front of the campfire for some
more looters shooter discussion I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a Lord who truly
exemplifies chasing the dream who is
undying passion and love of the destiny
franchise whether it be is amazing
multi-platform streams detailed how-to
videos or outstanding range servers all
done in the spirit of positivity and
Guardian inclusiveness introducing the
software developer + creator and host of
the CV Grey YouTube and twitch channels
the glory correctly recognizes vault of
glass as one of the top rates and the
leader of the grilled-cheese community
Vic is debut at the campfire of the last
word mommy
Lord CB gray how you doing sir wow that
was quite the intro I think the most
like - shows I've ever heard my name's
CB gray you can call me Christian you
can call me CV you can call me the
potato making a whole lot of potato egg
I don't deserve that ensure that I just
got you can call me Lord potato I'm very
very grateful to be here
I want to before we get any further in
the podcast give a huge shout out to a
bonus give a huge shout out to Lord
Cognito these guys kill it and they're
amazing and I'm just
very very honored to be able to you know
sit down and talk about some destiny man
that's what it's all about you know
being around good people and just having
fun so I'm grateful hope we have a lot
of fun today um I feel like everything I
could have said about myself cuz we got
you know me very very happy to be here
and I'm excited to get into it so thank
you guys I appreciate it absolutely cool
project have you been so definitely get
started usually ask a couple questions
about a guest
stuff like that so for you man you've
been doing this a long time and I'll
just see your journey and stuff so what
really got you infatuated it's crazy
franchise that all of us loves me what
what tell us about that journey oh man
so we're destiny it kind of dates back
to before destiny so before destiny I
had an xbox when I was like really young
and so I did play some halo with someone
friends we mean sometimes when I
remember like one of my best friends we
would stay up all night playing Halo
together so I knew about Bungie already
so when I heard that Bungie was making a
new game around
III time when it first like you know was
starting to get some traction and
they're starting to talk about it that's
when destiny was really on my radar and
then seeing that one trailer they had
what their when it looked like
astronauts on space like you know like
you know exactly what I'm talking about
yeah that that um really raised my
curiosity and then after seeing the the
og alpha and beta oh I was already I by
that point I was like alright this is my
game I gotta have it gotta have it and
so I ended up you remember the white ps4
that one don't put the ass for just the
yeah yeah so that my sesh I still got
the old control this thing has been
honestly it's been through every
the analog stick is is pulled off like
this please been through war with me but
they said we bought bought the the og
ps4 lady with destiny when it came out
in a man
the rest was really history it was then
the biggest thing that kind of sorted
for me once we got going to was the
multiplayer because it was that was on a
different level I feel like back in was
that 2014 2014 I know so 66 plus years
ago yeah like that multiplayer
experience was something that even
though I played other multiplayer games
I never like never been a part of
anything like that and that's really
what made me fall in love and why six
years later we're still playing like you
know like that's amazing that that's
really what what started me though but
it was it was seeing it was knowing a
little bit about Bungie before knowing
what they were about and seeing the
trailers leading up to it then testing
it and my brother had it too my one of
my best friends had it in next thing you
know I was that was really what kicked
it off for me yeah same same here man
now the question I also would ask and
follow-up to that because obviously you
know I mean he was telling you before we
started that uh we kind of started where
was we were flash but before we the last
word and it was kind of not the greatest
time and that's it was like right around
curse of Osiris okay so my question to
you is like what made you stick is
shattered captain what's what made you
stick with it even during the tough
times because it was it was it was
smaller times better CB we went through
some peaks and valleys with destiny I
agree
uh once again honestly the people mmm
you know it was it was honestly the
people cuz it really just wasn't cursed
Osiris time II people forget like there
is a huge here I spill to around POA
time yes before taken King that was rice
go before the dress spilled the baddest
because I mean and I just feel like
there just came a point in time where
you know when you have your
group of friends it's just I mean that's
really what kind of firm especially for
me too because sometimes people asked
even even more in the future it's like
well how do you you know not get bored
playing the same thing that in the same
day every single time doing the same
activities and I always say it's more
the experience with the people with just
the game is kind of the platform but not
really it's not really that's not really
all there is to it there's a little more
magic involved with it
and that's really what's always like
kind of kept me going through those
times especially and honestly is why one
of the reasons why I want to get more
into creation as well in terms of
content was to be able to have more of
like you know a community of like that
just felt like a family you know we're
all just playing the game we love cuz
that's really what's always kind of kept
me through it like cuz that would that
was the biggest thing around I remember
still like wasn't like yesterday like
after beating that school lost 35 asleep
or you know but after we beat that and
it's late it's still like June and we
don't have taken King till September and
we don't even know what taking king is
yeah so we don't even know that we have
a slam dunk waiting that happens and no
one knew that we knew it was murky
you're right it was yeah yes oh so it
was really kind of bleak back then too
and like you know everybody was very
like it was the first time we never read
so it was just it was also a different
time was like well this the first we
don't have a raid so people were really
kind of very controversial at that time
so yes it was but yes that was pretty
controversial so um that was really what
kept what was what kept me going was you
know all the friends that I had and kind
of you know making those memories
together then yeah so then and that's
really what I've leaned on always no
doubt no doubt no no your other question
for our past teeth um the other thing is
one thing I got to give you a lot of
credit not only do you multi-platform
stream which is awesome bringing all
your different communities together but
the day also like is that brain
shivering man like that's not easy now
that's not easy and that is is a gift a
labor of love I could you know I'm
saying do you're able to bring someone
in who maybe has no experience with a
raid and my opinion you know raise or
one of the s the premiere content got me
to kind of stick around and say why this
game has tremendous potential so like
it's just as far as like how did that
gate start as far as like helping people
out
during
cuz I think that's really cool well it
dates back to like really back to a time
where I feel like I was in kind of the
reverse situation like in the around
taking King time I'd really have a lot
of people to do orcs with I'm a bets
kind of went III didn't have a lot of
people to do raids with myself or any
other activities at that for a while and
so I kind of just wanted to have a place
where I could have women 8b I guess this
struggle that I had back then for other
people and I really can't take all the
credit for that rate help anyways
there's so many likely no other people
in our community to that um really all
come together and love rates too and
also want to as a community come and
bring new kind of Guardians their
experience because it is tough I mean
nah there's no one person that can bring
five people throw rain and so it's
really cool that like seeing everybody
kind of come together and try to bring
new experiences to guardians that
haven't got a chance to play the raids
cuz I have people that come into every
stream and are like I've never done a
rate and destiny one or destiny - and
that's Wow six six years so so you know
people but it doesn't mean people don't
want to it's just kind of that barrier
to entry so I do I'm a I'm happy that
whether it's raids or exotic quest
weapons so take like whisper outbreak or
whatever the case may be I just really
like my whole thing when getting into
content creating was trying to eliminate
those blockers to entry that I kind of
felt at certain parts of my own kind of
gaming experience back in destiny one
especially so that's what really made me
want to do it and then when you hear
somebody scream at the top of their
lungs when they get 1k it's all you need
so yeah yeah when you hear somebody's
reaction or see somebody and gets out
breakers or whatever the case may be and
you know to see how happy and and just
the reaction is really what I mean
that's kind of you can't put a value
okay put a value on every now that dates
back the Gjallarhorn so you know you
never you never forget you never forget
where you are all you're doing when I
first dropped it oh yeah what you got
for me it's cool dude man cool do see me
do you man after all that stuff I don't
even know we're gonna start
awesome just like love in the community
and raid Sherpas I mean it's just what
we dispense it back what did you guys
what got you guys into this thing back
to you
probably some very similar to yours as
well kind of got me into my nightfall so
Louis and stuff like that was I played
vault of glass time taking King I had
some friends that stuck with it like you
know I had a friend who had a couple
friends that gamed and stuff like that
and they stuck for a little while but
they started slowly trickling off and
you run out of friends to play with
those like all right I still want to do
night falls kind of a cool challenge to
do by myself and it's like all right if
I can do this I want to see if I can
help other people do it so like going
through and trying to actually do these
things and especially nightfall solos in
d1 those were tough because that was
back when it booted you'd orbitary on
top of that I can't tell you how many
times I said the same thing to go
through and do that but it was like
after doing those like shield brothers
was always my example I got to the point
where I was like I need this guy knees
it's like 185,000 damage on the first
set that I send him out of the room
these guys come over here shoot a rocket
over here turn I get the guys coming up
to like get to the point where I can let
everybody know what's coming enough even
people in the comments would say thank
you even my fire team of three I sent
this to them so at least we know what's
coming and it's like if I get really
like know the nuances of the strike and
know what's coming and stuff like that
it was always really really helpful in
the same thing it's like I always wanted
to try and be a guide for people who
think they might not be able to do it
themselves and then when I see the
comments later of like man I never
thought I could do this but thank you
actually like I finished it today
doesn't matter if it's six months later
on the video I'm like that's freaking
awesome though that's got me angry
everything is like just just trying to
help all right I'm on PC yeah he's okay
he's okay he's BC bonus has made some
very very helpful things - he's so good
that's what they are it's just he's very
welcoming to someone who may not is
completely new and he doesn't assume
like a lot of you assume that they've
you've been there before and they know
everything he talks to his audience in a
cool way from me it's different I mean I
kind of similar you in a sense RCB that
a big Bungie guys halo was huge for me
if that back from Halo 1
well you know creating mock LAN parties
for TV you know we were like addicted to
this Gators before Xbox Live so I'm
showing my age but at the end of the day
like you know we I love that company so
I just like you when I heard they're
announcing a new franchise and I'm like
okay destiny was is I had that helpful
yeah yeah you know you just I remember
not only was the skyboxes it was the
music just that boot up and you heard
Marty's theme and they have one of the
best soundtracks any any franchise yes
Marth they don't win any musical it
wasn't the end of the day I just like
man this thing's captivated me now I
mustn't miss out the Forte in the
building little brother things so um get
that the thing that captivated me was
okay the game was fun but in the
beginning I'll be honest once I hit that
max level and you beat the campaign yeah
I kind of cooled off because I didn't
understand the end game yeah I didn't
know what it was using back then there
was losing it was confusing I was kinda
like array it was cool but I thought it
would be more and I cooled off now shout
to sinister who's in the chat you know
I'm saying he's the one that said bro
you've got a range we got to get you to
level 30 it was a crime back then right
then I finally got there and I'll never
forget it was the vault of glass change
the game and change my life change guys
you know for console we didn't have
anything like race so it's a first
person shooter raid this whole
mysteriousness building the spire and
going deeper and there and I'm like oh
you know by name - my terrible water
jumps you know dirty jumping puzzle -
and the whole thing was - is when you're
in patrol when like before I ever jumped
in to rate like it's all other people
doing game and I was like what are they
doing
can I go yeah so that's like I gotta
figure out what this is wrong dad right
there
changed my life in there from nan I'm
like this game especially and I said
more people need to experience it so I
ended up becoming don't say like people
I would say either of dusty but I ended
up becoming the
vendor of destiny the only everybody
we're coming like why are you still
playing that game why are you still and
I'm just like man I love it me and like
you say it's the community your friends
get on and that's it so that's kind of
what did it for me man tremendous no I
agree it sounds like it's some book some
qualities of that multiplayer again that
we were taught that raid experience was
different than anything else that I'd
ever been apart a bit of auto yeah ever
completely pleased over this thing look
to be honest yes that a raid ranking
video oh yeah some things in there that
are really some things actually I was
like you know what I agree there's some
things I was like okay so here get down
that s tier I want you to break down
there st of the top raids for CP but a
people that oh wait I so now wait wait
let's let's also like I guess clarify
are we talking about in general are we
talking about just in this current game
no we're gonna talk about in general oh
okay great see see it's so tough when I
give this answer sometimes I feel like
the first one that I always put up is
the first one but then like his bone and
glass for me is is like always gonna be
the best experience memory taken here
you is the best gaming experience I've
probably ever had whether people are
agree or not like I always have it in
this more so even just because of like
bus I mean you can say there's been
better bosses you can say there's been
bigger raids you can say there's been
more encounters but just the mystery the
the the fact that they got it right on
the first time the loop the breakdown of
this on hard and normal so there was
actually incentive to do hard like
getting faith bringer do it 10 years in
a row they've been till you get it
finally everybody I know who has grand
new fate ring understands yeah the
amount of lore that was attached to it
with Preta thing to fear and all of that
enriched loot I am war you know just the
whole experience
was just wanna it was just on a
different level and part of it's like
one of those things where it's like
alright well yeah now obviously a bunch
of making more raids but back then when
they did it in 2014 it was just it was
just almost like I had to be there a
type thing hmm like so so no matter what
I always defend that read them out now
so now I want to shout out a couple
people to check because they have a big
reveal a shout out to Leon
he said Vox save destiny a huge game
chamber now that question I got before
we begin to tell the rigs I obviously
I'm a Vox fanboy so I gotta blow I got a
blow v8 so I'm not even worried I'm just
go now I don't but question to you is
what do you say to the people like Forte
and all the people who say you know
we're just looking at it going it's
really not that that good or a what do
you say to those people I mean it's just
one of those things where like the best
comparison I could give is we all have
live in houses with internet right like
and so internet snails very like a
normal thing in everybody's house right
but back when the internet first came
about like everybody you've realizes how
much the internet changed the world and
if you said that energy didn't change
the world then now an internet internet
it's normal now right we all got an
arrow it's completely normal now and now
that we have 10 raids I understand
people saying the thing about what they
say but but you can't say that Internet
didn't change everything what a glass
will be that internet that's the best
way I could put it in it I mean fight if
you don't understand like I feel like
that's hopefully clearest anything I
could I could compare to be honest and
on the first day that was like
that would be my opinion it'd be the
best comparison that I can make like I
get that now it's like yeah Internet's
everybody's house now there's so in the
equivalent did that be now I understand
there's been raised with more in
calendars I understand that bunches been
able to experiment more I understand
that you know there's there's more that
Bungie can do and now we're gonna even
start moving to stronger like when we
have next-gen consoles throw be more
ability to do new things we oughta
remember that we were in the realm of
ps3 Han sex mics so there was there was
like from a technical standpoint there
is also limitations that they had to
adhere to yes so like it's just what
they were able to do back then like even
if like now wouldn't take as much effort
back then was I mean it was it was a
they did a thing there they did a thing
no not fair enough brother they think we
got we got fault so gimme some more of
your other top theorem it would three
things for I fight Kings Falls another
one that I feel like changed a whole lot
of everything again I feel like once
again King's ball took things to another
notch as well I know people also have
some reservations about certain parts at
Kings fold the one part that I always am
at least they gave would it be like I
feel like aware of and cognizant of is I
feel like the last encounter like making
people go the four rounds I know it
wasn't always people's favorite yeah but
just in general from an overall rate
experience like from the ships and I'm
out of detail and the ships and
everybody remembers falling off the
ships a hundred thousand times faster
and the ships totems to the to then
having more priests to then golgoroth
which before it was learned that you
could do one bubble was probably one of
the best encounters never once again I
mean back and forth anybody did the
golgoroth norm art mode worked really
good at counter yeah that to jump in the
bridge everybody so what were their
grades and rotate around but so anybody
who like yes so I feel like golgoroth
the way it was intended to be was still
wanted probably the best encounters that
I feel like I've been a part of and then
sisters and then sisters kind of
teaching them what kind of went on into
work and then once again all the extra
secrets that were in the Kings fall raid
the basketball room all the different
stuff that was within within Kings fall
once again I
I have that one up for another just the
overall experience again the secret
chest then you've got unlock if he
jumped on the side and one of the ramp
like well all the different stuff that
the touch of malice that was associated
with it and need the loot and then
having to loot split between the heart
and normal once again there was just
there was once again there's a lot of
things that Bungie got right it with
Kingsville as well even if the last
encounter didn't make you do it four
times in a row I still I still have it
up there for sure that would be another
one I put up mmm give my mom one more
toddler just do it a top three so give
me one more I know it's tough it's like
picking your children I understand it is
the last two I have liked and I don't
want to just like not put anything from
do to because then it seems like um like
I probably throw like last wish in there
probably too I thought I'd throw a last
wish under and then it would be like man
so hard then probably over at the
machine is an honorable mention but but
yeah I probably stick last switch over
from a main man but then the whole
outbreak thing I love so much about it
would be one hat off but I really did
like last wish to and I think every
single encounter and last wish was was
really good I think there was once again
a lot of Secrets and last wish I think
the overall first day experience is one
of the best first thing that's best um
probably the best first day since Kings
balls first yes um so there's a whole
lot of good stuff with the last wish as
well all the way down to the new exotic
that was attached the world's first for
it then triggered everything the
Dreaming city a lot of stuff that went
on with last wish that I think also was
like you could say game-changing as well
so that would probably my three nicely
personalized for those reasons and I
hope I gave you some decent reasons home
yeah yeah
wrong strong and I always tell people
look I know I'm a fault BAM boy but I'm
with you man like as far as you know
last wish everything you said as far as
loud Kings fall to me I can't get mad at
anyone if they have those eyes they're a
steer in any order yeah because for each
reason that you gave yeah I can
understand it mmm sure for sure
what else you got II know Thank You
Dairy we got to go in here man go see me
I wanted to ask you see before like any
of your videos and stuff that you made
or any of that are like have kind of a
special place for you did something
really cool that you didn't expect or
you know just any certain videos cuz
I've got a couple of course that have
been like hey this is really cool this
one got some cool reactions any standout
videos that you've made the chair
they're really proud of either you know
did really well helped a lot of people
stuff like that um hmm just like
standouts in terms of videos um there
was like there's there's a few like sirs
one ERA videos that I used to make about
two years ago it's funny around the
warmind time which was when I don't know
if you guys remember do you remember
when the black spindles catalyst was
early at the time people thought was
black spinels catalyst inducer learns
catalyst yes yeah but this before we all
knew it was whispered the room so we
actually got some same black spindle for
a reason because we know it was whisper
yet but so when black spindles we
thought this catalyst was in the the
what's in the database from like GG
obviously and so those those I remember
like I did that whole build-up and wore
mine which ended up bearing fruit to
whisper of the worm was a really cool
segment of the channel we're making
videos kind of like it was almost like
where is this weapon and this weapon
actually enough existing was one time
that was really cool another time coming
off of the night now be lab stream that
we ended up having which surprised still
one of my favorite experiences even
though it was like you know I took a
couple days for things to get locked but
after that to the whole process of
getting together a fireteam that we had
and and going through the mysterious
data pat on the first day to and then
getting that video out to was was also a
really fun experience I still remember
being with fed and gypsy that day that
was really really a fun day as well that
was a really cool video to make after
that came out um but honestly I really
enjoy all and just every single video
for the reason I've just seen the
comments like you said when you somebody
comments back and says that you know
this was really helpful with whatever
it's it's really that's really like
they're all pretty special I really just
enjoy
seeing just the reactions that that
they've helped people and then it kinda
just makes it all worth it
so I have something that definitely have
been some fun wants to make I also
enjoyed the making an overall to stream
highlights that I felt like kind of
captured the the timeline of all the
kind of streams that I had done over the
years I thought that was that was a
pretty fun one to watch too but overall
I really do my most I guess favorite
thing about the videos in general is
just when you make a video and then you
see that somebody said it it was helpful
with them getting whatever the video
title was about and that that's really
what makes each one of them special like
that's really what does it for me with
the videos has seen the reactions I'm
always definitely fulfilling my brother
down they're all about the reaction give
it back just see any effect that you
have on people so cool so cool love what
you doing man saying how we feeling
about destiny like well whatever what's
your yeah what should take right what's
the energy for you like so so I feel
like I have like a very I'm not
interesting opinion but I just have like
reservations about getting on there like
destinies in trouble train because I
really feel like we're in an era that's
still affected from the split yeah from
Activision I mean one thing and
especially like now to like in terms of
trying to get effective changes out
quick one thing that I know that you
know you're an IT and so I'm also a
developer too and one thing right now is
we're all working from home obviously as
you know with the pandemic that we have
going on right now and one of the
biggest things that I've noticed at
least personally is we're working on a
small scale application and it's really
it's really hard having everybody be in
all these different places and just
trying to get anything done and so like
so one thing is I'm trying not to crack
down too much on some changes taking
longer because I understand that
managing a game the size of destiny and
with everybody from home is just not
realistic
I mean it's so tough doing it on a small
scale so in terms of the short term
changes I'm trying to like I mean I feel
like destiny like IRA Bungie in general
I'm trying not to be too hard in terms
of the time that were
in right now apps but then also in terms
of losing Activision in general I feel
like butts in by person with in my
personal opinion I feel like that's
something we're gonna feel the effects
of till September and so and so well I'm
okay with what we have now as long as
what I what I'm hoping is coming in
September it's gonna be the slam dunk
that most of the September's have been
oh yeah and so like so it is you know is
the PvE in the absolute best place that
it can be maybe not as pvp and the best
place to convene maybe not but I do
think those times are coming and and I
think with the more interactive twelve
so that we're getting and and some of
the signs that are starting to show I
really do think that that that we're
okay and there's been a lot there's been
plenty of times in destiny where we've
been in like you know a little bit know
yeah the Browns have been more than this
ever has been yeah yeah yeah so we've
had way worse than this and I think
Bungie always if kind of you know shines
in those type of moments I'm not really
too worried about it and I think that it
obviously things could always be better
but like but sometimes things being
better I don't know if it's realistic
and I just don't know what really stupid
like I don't know a lot of studios that
could lose some as big as Activision and
just have things go without a hitch
exact technical standpoint so yeah it's
major so I got a question for you
as we're talking about like September
and the fall by the way he'd see through
ka says here the goat he just wants you
to know that but no this actually kind
of ties into something for you so I've
done my speculations we've talked about
this of what's coming with the light
bright wall which you may be too young
to know but like we've got the you know
little lights showing up on the wall
we've got these little videos in boiling
of CB gray the man of the actual tinfoil
hat from where the hell did they intend
fly had come to yes you have to put it
on and three what do you think is coming
first I got to put it on right I think
with all this hair it is gotten over the
once it's become harder and harder and
harder to put this thing on really no
wait we got it on so first thing we got
it that's also a great question so one
thing that I think the Destiny community
does more than any other community is we
do a lot of witch hunting and we do a
lot of swimming oiling into the rice and
we could see one tiny little crack on
the oil the next amino rate secrets is
on average they're honest is this this
blade aggress was just slightly curved
and now we're were theorize and I love
that that is something I love about this
community so much and I think it's led
to so much fun then that you know is
sometimes generated over something that
doesn't even exist sometimes some of the
most fun moments that I've had in
destiny and so what happened with the
tinfoil hat like that dates back to once
again what I was saying originally with
war mind when originally the first thing
that came out was that there's a
catalyst in the database that looks very
similar to black spindle when the world
in the world is it if this weapons in
the game why don't we have it why don't
we have an and so that led us in to the
time of the videos that I was telling
you about the theory in their kind of
called the theory videos we were kind of
trying to figure out where in the world
this weapon was in the game and so the
first thing was that tipped everybody
off if you remember one of my favorite
things about destiny 2 is strike loot
also - so I love like all the way back
to destiny 1 the grasp amount likes the
next up always all of the different
amazing strike loot those in the game
and that also held true indie - one of
the things that kept me going in
Christmas iris and war mind was some of
the strike loot so DF
a duty bound for a sec osprey I missed
those actually now and you know as well
as I'm still missing one silicon neuroma
yes you so don't have well damn
no no I'm saying I was missing saying
wow my favorite sniper
oh no Irina it's all good no no yeah
yeah no I love it but so with that being
said there was one more strike in the
game that didn't drop a weapon it was
the only one and it was all sold and
drop a weapon it was only a transmat
effect no only a transman impact and so
foil and so next thing you know we're
looking very very hard in that strike
because it just didn't add up those only
strike at the time that didn't have a
weapon attached to it or at least like
at that point in time a like cosmetic
type drop of drops like you could take
like Guardian world for example where
the nut that's where the universal
wavefunction was dropping it's like that
that was a ship though it wasn't uh like
a transmat effect it just that was
almost it just it seemed like if
something was off it felt like something
was off so next thing you know we there
is these pyramids upside down pyramids
that were in the the soul strike that we
ended up finding like on the stream and
so next thing you know like I was like
me and then my friend that they were
like the rest of the world we're all
just jumping to try to figure out what
in the world these pyramids can mean
that's when I became really good friends
with sweat because what was also a
wondering what in the world was one of
these pyramids that's when we became
really good friends as well mmm and so
next thing you know this this spawned a
whole lot of theories on where the
weapon could be until it actually ended
up showing up that same season and that
was all that spin foiling or ten foiling
turned into like whenever anything is
like you know whenever we're speculating
anything in the game were ten foiling no
matter what the case may be so the new
is the new biggest thing that time flew
about right now in terms of the game
that everybody knows about is the
Doritos Elias based Doritos exactly know
and so the Doritos in the game obviously
are very representative of the darkness
and so now really everybody's question
is when is it coming because it's coming
right it seems like it's coming that's
okay when is it coming and then what's
gonna happen when they come and
that that hopefully that answers
questions at least on the whole 10
flowing and now that that's held true
now with like Niobe labs and we were
starting to see the symbols before it so
in the forges when you can see the
symbols on the ground before you can
actually get to Niobe that held true for
you can see the symbols in the the in
before the st. in the st. 14 mission the
way when we were saving him yeah see
those symbols that were in the corridors
of time before the actual quarters a
time next he know I'm screenshot and all
these images like where these four and
then ended up being for one of the
longest marathons Oh probably just need
like I mean that was that was a
sleepless week for me but like but that
type of stuff like is some of that's
that's some of my favorite stuff in
investing in general and so in the
seeker missions as well but um so that's
really what spawned the whole tin foil
thing in terms of what we do hopefully I
was a good answer that's that's freaking
amazing that's what I wanted to hear
it's like I'd seen that wanted to ask
about a chat head to hear about it even
if they knew about it but we're like the
wall this week the first little Dorito
on the wall it blaze made if you do yeah
is on them yes so it's like it's by
Neptune are we gonna get a cinematic and
I'm wondering now is like Guardian games
finishes this week Tuesday next week is
literally the first day on the calendar
of the 12th that's not on the calendar
for the seasoning there yeah there's
nothing there so it's very very
interesting what's going up in Tuesday I
completely agree with you another thing
that definitely like once again if you
wanted to continue 10 foiling about
would be to go back look at the shadow
keep by doc or whatever that talked
about season 10 11 and 12 they come and
they mentioned season season um 11 is
gonna be unlike any other sensor season
destiny that's a quote they said season
11 is gonna be unlike any season like
destiny now what does that mean you also
see my recent tweet did you see the
recent week from Lord Luke Smith did you
see your some of the one from yesterday
or one furling today or take up an oven
no that was yesterday or the day
it was recently last Aircel late for
words it's all yet though mmm you are
not prepared you are
oh man but usually I'm usually on top of
that but yes so but I agree so we're not
prepared for whatever it is so I am very
very much curious to see what's
happening not only towards the end of
this season because I'm hoping that it's
gonna like kind of facilitate whatever's
gonna come in season 11 and then I'm
interested to see what's coming in
season 11 and if ultimately when season
12 comes is there gonna be this gigantic
like execution of Planets mob man like
that is that is that coming and so you
know it's just one of the most popular
things everybody's kind of you know
leaning towards because a we need more
game space anyways yeah but the you know
I mean but one of my big things to and
you guys can kind of give me your
thoughts on this mm-hmm but Rasputin
obviously in the bunker we can see all
of the planets lit up all the way to
Saturn right yes and then we can see the
Doritos way at the edge of the solar
system but for some reason a couple of
those planets aren't lit up what does
that mean cuz I mean they they've been
blown up already why can why can't we
see them why Uranus and Neptune aren't
lit up at all that your question why
yeah why yeah we don't know we don't
know I was like my guess Neverland
Shores that we've never ventured that
far like we went to Saturn or your urine
our Jupiter we meant Saturn we've been
near most of these places Europa's not
lit up though which is also strange like
saying it or not but yeah yeah I agree
with you in south one-eighth it's just
because he can't reach that far or
because people like oh he just can't see
that Forks we haven't been there yet but
I was like then why can you see the
darkness that's at the edge edge yeah so
if Y is the Kuiper belt like listed out
there like you know forever out there so
so it's all very interesting stuff so
it's it's there's there's a lot in like
that might back back to what I told you
before like this is the most fun part is
you know all of the build-up so like I'm
asking you that question even even
though I don't know the answer so you
know it's more of a it's a question that
doesn't even have an answer
but it's all it's all interesting stuff
it's all real interesting yeah but you
man okay that's the story that Tim Foyle
now my Harris is trying to eat this
thing off how short is that thing gonna
go how far is that coming down that's a
great question how longer this gets the
more it might just be everything you
know oh you're really twins I might
actually get a head set on my head why
don't you wear a headset like do you see
my hair there's but I love the tinfoil
and that was really cool man I'm getting
so many theories and we're excited too
because it we know about this game if
you're thinking about a life service
game you're gonna have those peaks in
those valleys and you know the cool
thing is every symptom you know saying
they always knock it out the park so
anytime anyone is like questioning
that's not always find it funny because
I'm not all your leaving will seems like
cool and if you've been around the block
like we have you know how it is you know
I'm saying and you made a great point
about these sources about about the emic
right now you know and us like I said
from a technical it is to do things
remotely but like you said we're in a
holding pattern me and ER the same page
we're not going super crazy we
understand the climate yeah
but we also know that that you know that
the majority of the resources will be
heading towards this new content and you
never would be mater and all these other
stuff that they got doing so we're
pretty excited man and we know like I
said it's like EU put it perfect like
you know on a 12 like 30 games you know
so like what's gonna happen it literally
is all we know about the 12 literally
four full week so we have us and more
that's it yeah all we have and they have
told us nothing about it
we've got pyramid ships coming in we
have an almighty which has been like the
start of the season and then left
hanging out there we're shooting these
satellites up there to take care of it
so at some point we've got to shoot that
thing there's rumors if you guys haven't
heard
you know things possibly crashing down
I'm not gonna say too much but there may
be a little little damage and
destruction in places we've got all this
slate we started with the almighty now
their pyramids are basically made the
almighty look like a chump as long as
the almighty is taken care if we still
have much bigger fish to fry
oh yeah and then but again it's like
utterances well yeah but you picture the
scale - we'll talk about the table in a
little while it's like hey we're not
making any major changes for season 11
but man season 12 year for like holy
crap
like there is a potential for so much to
be coming changing drastic things
potentially with you know as you guys
have say planets potentially not being
in the mix anymore and I've won I talked
about this with my brother too is like
so if one of the MIT planets goes away
and Titan seems to be a pretty popular
candidate if Titan goes it's only got
one strike on and stuff but it's like
some of just the vanilla story still
goes through that planet like are they
gonna rewrite the story is that just
gonna be a story of a different era is
the Sloan whole campaign not gonna be
there with the vault like there's
certain things that they move that
constant questions yeah and I mean that
goes all the way down the lake even
which is Titan like that even the
Thornton
strike is ya dependent on that and so it
looks like it's gonna there's gonna be
rework if there are things exploding cuz
people also say like well what about IO
but then it's like alright what happens
to whisper yeah so me and I'm yeah
that's gonna be a part of my heart
ripped out if that happens but it but
yeah yeah yeah but it's one of those
things that they're fake like they're
they have to be asking themselves those
questions so I'm sure they're gonna be
reworking either I guess how the the new
light story works or I don't know if if
you get rid of resources like in general
like if you don't have to plan it's in
the game are you still able to like
access planets just in small scale in
terms of like a quick story mission
strike it's like blurry background it's
not they're like so I don't really know
how that works from I guess the
technical establish I guess that's one
thing that I I'm hoping they're asking
themselves because it's something that
if not done correctly I feel like it
could receive backlash well it's like I
can't get this anymore I can't run this
anymore like it's just not available
like you know so they gotta find out how
to accommodate that
Eggman I think that okay no no you
you're good no I was just saying that I
think that at least short term history
has shown
dad look at the Izanagi is it alright
what the way forges have now been
reworked as far as that whole quest line
yeah cuz now everything the forgers are
now kind of like on you want a tater
right on the planet so I think that if
it comes down to it whether it be
tighten or whatever they will still give
access to these quest laws I cannot see
a situation where budget says you know
what a man you know if you had thought
you don't say you're gonna get in a war
you don't say like well whatever
anything that's associated with passing
through Titan more strike related that
they will probably make ass accessible
another way yeah
that's my initial theory you know I'm
saying yeah yeah I think it could be
done I think it could be yeah I mean and
they've already done a lot of tweaking
of Cuesta a lot of people times people
don't even realize I mean even say like
speaking to the forged weapons like you
said like yotan and lemon aren't random
anymore
those are now 10 frames which is kind of
hefty if the powerful ones too so five
weeks but so yeah they've already done
some tweaking in the past so it's not
anything that we know be outlandish for
us to say that they could just you know
change the kind of the course of how it
goes but it'll all be stuff that they
need to ask those questions cuz those
weapons still need to definitely be
accessible especially the exotics
because I believe those are as of now
not gonna be retired I think that's what
Luke right right yes so so yeah so
definitely exotics are one that they're
got to ask the questions and try to
figure out what's the best way to handle
them hopefully Bungie angels at the
right way everything is so tied together
at this point we've had this back and
forth that Sun setting and exotics and
this whole thing has been a thing but
but I mean you bring up a great point of
like how how do you pick and choose like
if this planet goes is this just now a
random drop somewhere else and the
question just no longer is yeah if you
blow up IO just whisper the worm just
become a rain ablute drop for the people
who don't have it if you haven't seen it
anymore it's like I mean I'm it
Whisperer is one of my biggest videos
I've ever done so I was like it's at a
special place for me too and that's one
of those when you just like how I
believe that's how I first found you
which is an amazing video there's been a
big you know the last week we go animate
amazing amazing video because this man
everyone in exotics also to be retired
and um you know I I struggled I bet they
would love to Lester to get retired
right now are you freaking kidding don't
see don't be cute because now see visa
mmm to us you know I wouldn't mind if 0
had to go away and I was like because
those secret missions are probably it's
my favorite like I love helping people
with those it's gonna be very sad just
but like I definitely would like that
was like and I'm I'm with you on trust
me the secret missions have all been so
freaking amazing like talking to nine
hydras about those at Guardian con when
he's part of the one like the artistry
that made um shattered thrown at some
point is another one when I wonder it's
like if shattered thrown when the
Dreaming city if it ever gets fixed if
that story thread is done technically
shatter thrown shouldn't even be there
cuz that whole thing is the end of the
three weeks cycle so there are some
major pieces to these exotics at a point
and we look honestly when we look at the
table which I was gonna wait to get into
a little bit but when you look and they
say like a year for a year five years
six in this discussion we all
potentially talked about late hey win is
d3 coming the more the way you've read
between the lines on the table this week
makes you think d3 is Bartha getting
farther and farther away to be honest
with you so that's what it's like so
might caught my question to him was
basically just like his d2 somehow they
push d2 in the next-gen and it's still
going was is whisper the worm if you
have a year of six or seven raid should
you be able to take whisper the worm
into it and be able to infuse it into it
that was the question I try and ask this
occasionally what do you talk about it
do you think use whisper brew like ear
six
and just keep taking a horde or yes but
I mean we've never had a game yet where
we've had six years I feel like we start
having to ask ourselves some tough
questions and I even love whisper I am I
it would it I didn't leave have to start
contemplating it because I definitely
don't like I do want there to be like
incentive to go get some of these new
things in the game like I mean I could
take for example I feel like some of the
like let's say bunker weapons or even
before that let's take the the the
weapons from the back with the fractal
line weapons permit before then we're
back with weapons we were getting before
I feel like we weren't using them
because we had so many like other
weapons that are just like you know
right are always gonna we're always
gonna ever close we're always gonna and
we're always gonna mount up we're always
gonna have this and that and the third
so by year six I mean if we're having
this problem like or kind of having this
problem now I I at least would have to
admit that it would have to be a
discussion right we are we need to like
way different possibilities for for just
trying to figure out how to make other
weapons viable I mean that's a tough
that in that and just that sentence
alone is not easy I just leave you can't
just snap and make things viable like or
without you know breaking things
sometimes you don't want to break
anything because you know we break
things I mean to disable things and then
it's just a whole nasa l-- so so it's
tough if the game goes into year six to
a bonus this point i would at least have
to discuss it i feel like in my opinion
it would have to be discussed that's a
total but we've never had a situation
where that the game go that long
absolutely my you're making a fantastic
point yeah all I'm saying is everything
seemed that you were mentioning and a
lot of what you were mention also
involved legendary weapons which we we
came in the middle me he came in the
middle there was a hard fight we came at
him and I said you know what we gotta
discuss that I'm cool with the
retirement of these earlier weapons
because again redundancy loophole gets
you know inflated I get that when it
came to the exotics especially the ones
that involved west lines yeah zero hour
like whisper of the world that's where I
struggle because it was more of
respecting player engagement to get
those weapons are great because they do
those activities
right and exotics was such a small part
of the loophole that I'm like it's not
really gonna kill the game if those
still hung around I'm all about weapon
retirement but legendary you know and
moving therefore so that was just our
little beef let's take it back there
then because we've dealt with that
before though all of us as d1 players so
how did you feel we lost Gellhorn in ice
bricks
you know those weapons could we lost
those after what years have three after
yeah after which clear but you brought
yell horn back then you lost it we Borg
Alabama back about talking about like
the initial reaction just like kind of
putting yourself in before we it was
rise of iron obviously a reservoir and
we got black Gjallarhorn back but like
we didn't immediately so we have these
links yes I was wondering how you guys
felt when that happened I think for me
originally with Gjallarhorn specifically
as uh as a random drop it didn't affect
I think the difference I feel with d1
and d2 is that d2 seems to have a lot of
more lore and exotic quest oriented
acquisition
I feel d2 had more of that way as d1 I
think a lot of it came from random drops
and I think I just struggled my issue is
I struggle when you create these law
requests and yeah all these steps to get
something and now you're saying okay
after a certain amount of time now you
can't now that you can't use it yes it
will exist yeah
from from pinnacle activity you won't be
able to use that's that's my struggle so
maybe they could maybe they could even
break down another class of exotics been
there that are tied to actual like
activity type based exotics and maybe
those could stay maybe you can make an
argument for those then um sorry what if
you spent ten years to get if it took
like a long time for it finally to to
get like you know a 1k to drop let's say
that orange II just did not bless it
took you five hundred times to get 1k
and it finally dropped let people use
that one kick save they were like versus
I guess if like let's say a son shot
dropped out of an Engram then maybe
retires that one so like so maybe if
maybe if we used our you know like an
exaggerated exotic retirement type thing
almost at that point almost yeah like we
almost have to like break down a
subsection of exotics
I you know that's how I'll be flexible
to the conversation we could figure it
out we figure out come you know we can
work it out deeper yeah yeah the defense
cards coming e/wd presentation like I
said I out like you said do you use out
breaker in your trials or God you know
what I still use I'll break it I'm
actually running a zero hour during this
time it's bugged with all the extra
damage that's not mugs anymore it's not
bug jump back in and man it was I have
been practicing again on the south it
it's not it's it felt even harder no I I
enjoyed it being broken for the time
that it was because it was interesting
they didn't say anything so I almost be
wondering if it was like not a bug but
they did go and fix it they fixed it yep
it was just like one of those like quiet
patch notes and be like oh yeah that's
that's in there we got a big table going
what else we got going on eat yeah so
it's actually not the biggest flaw but
we got some big big news so we all knew
last week that we talked about trials
and talked about we've had these
different topics they've been discussing
talked about bounties and seasons last
week we've had some discussion about
certain things and everybody was on the
edge of their seat this season or this
week because of we knew Everest and
rewards was cáñamo something almost
didn't expect but ever versus the big
topic at topic and how it ties into
rewards and before we actually get into
this just see be gray what are your
thoughts because we've had our VIN on it
just the status currently of it before
we go into what's gonna change where do
you think ever sits now good bad a
little too intrusive it's fine so as
always I've always thought that it's
like it's not a tough one it's always
tough because personally I don't I don't
usually I don't spend your money and
ever verse and it's not my favorite
because I feel like some nice - I'll see
pieces of loot no be like that really
should have been like here or there it's
like for an example like that heart be
ghosts in those in that red hive ship in
the red buoy it's Sarah I would have
loved if that ghost was festering course
strike specifically I would have loved
if that ship or that or that Sparrow was
this right specific loot for hash legume
who's crotas daughter she deserves a
strike yeah but
so that that's that's the one side
obviously cuz like that I feel very
strongly about some of the pieces of
gear and like I definitely would love to
see some of the other activities get
some love with some of the stuff that I
see in ever verse that sometimes matches
exactly the theme that's going on in
said activity H but then on the flip
side too I do realize that once again
they've they've lost a gigantic asset
and they wouldn't mean bunchy doesn't
know what he goes to bed like enjoying
getting negative feedback and they don't
enjoy getting negative feedback if they
wouldn't be doing what they're doing if
it wasn't helping to continue to bring
us what we're getting off in my opinion
no nobody nobody enjoys negative
feedback nobody like it's just not human
nature so I mean I do think that's one
of those things that is like if they're
doing it in the way that they're doing
it it's it's because it's necessary to
keep the ships going right now and so in
it clearly I mean as they're getting
traction and starting to get their legs
back it seems like all right now they're
scaling it back some which I mean
because now like I mean we didn't
mention it yet but obviously they're
starting to not attach some of those
those items like so ships ghosts some of
those aren't gonna be in that reverse
anymore sighting so I'm hoping that as
they're getting their footing back I'm
hoping that some of these like events
where you know like sometimes we have
these like events like a festival to
lost or a dawning and everything's
behind you know the pale or whatever and
so like I'm hoping that as we continue
to move forward like the best is yet to
come I mean I liked what I heard and so
III definitely I'm not the biggest fan
of a reverse but I understand that
they're like somehow bills need to be
paid in order to you know to work on the
game
well like I mean during the transition
of the lack of that you know Activision
and basically the big purse behind me
like alright so far this year people are
probably gonna be pissed off about it
we're gonna lean a little heavier into
the adversity we can make money and
we're gonna try and pull it back when
people really start to get annoyed by it
and that seems honest I mean no
illogical business sense it makes sense
they need to have let's see if we can
make some money as many places as we can
this is probably gonna be a bit
intrusive but if we can make a little
more here it's gonna help us on the
backend so we can kind of get settled in
and know what to expect for your for
fall expansion and all that stuff so
they go into and that's the first thing
you basically talked about is vanity and
accessories so couple big pieces I'm
just gonna kinda Haiti topic and we can
basically talk about it yeah first one
just literally straight out of the gate
the people probably been asking for four
years does will be adding a
transmogrification feature to destiny to
this will allow players to turn their
armor into universal ornaments we will
allow players to do this with in with
in-game effort or silver this feature is
in early development as expected
sometime during gear for now I saw even
people on Twitter asking hey what is the
in-game effort still honestly don't know
that's in question but just the fact
that transmog has come in wanted to get
each of your thoughts as you're the
guest C beat your first I think it's
pretty cool I mean I think that that's
something that people will love and I
also think they set it in the right way
where it sounds like if they said either
silver or in-game activities and that's
all I needed to hear if it was something
that I every time I had to pay to do it
I never do it I mean just personally I
never do it but um so it is it is nice
to hear that I mean I think it's a cool
feature and I think having both avenues
to unlock it is I think it's when with
your pinnacle gear drops you get an
ornament
so like token or something like that
right or you go do a raid or a dungeon
like go make it certain that actually
gives the people a reason to go in there
and then also reward the people who do
some of the hard stuff so I'm good with
that
yeah yeah cockney no soup actually
surprised isn't to see it just so boldly
written and now it was really cool you
know at the end of the day you know this
is something the community has always
want it we've we've kind of dipped our
toe in it you know I'm saying as far as
the early initial ornament stuff and
even blessing around so to see them
fully commit really cool I like the
option and I'm saying kinda like ICB
said you don't just silver also we got
to figure out what in-game effort is
though we got yeah that's true to gauge
what I it's a positive you did not be
mad at this and I love to see stuff like
this is dope
yeah so that was pretty much a big win
from the starters just like damn first
one here we go
okay so second piece each season we will
deliver an aspirational pursuit of armor
we haven't done this consistently in
dusty to this Armel will come from
activities no not the season pass nor
ever verse and this is each season by
the way as an example we removed and I
love this like this is one of those rare
things and you see them getting ready
for next season already making a change
as an example we removed the ever verse
armor from season 11 and itemized it
into an aspirational activity because
this is the right thing to do for the
for the game hmm I mean you guys want
anything that like sits in and speaks
for itself once again I mean first off
love the openness but being able to have
those types of drops in other activities
can bring so much more meaning to
certain activities that right now are
struggling to have to find any meeting
in one example I can give us strikes
like just in general if they start
attaching different items that people
actually want to some of these other
activities I'm sure people will start
running them again I don't think so so
they if they get this right I mean I
feel like it's gonna be great for the
game and I'm very happy with love it one
caveat for me is just that they I know
they attempted of some of this indie the
beginning of D - you know crucible
Harmar they're gonna you know I just
wonder this is be selfish
I would like to cool this factor to be
raised because I remember the initial
crucible armor set was I was not feeling
too many more set at all so booms again
my issue has always been the coldest
disparity from ever versus armor versus
what was actually achieved but the fact
that they're mentioning this I have
confidence that they're going to have
that level of detail and coolness and
stuff like that I just got to see it you
know saying because that was my always
my problem like the the ever verse stuff
just looks so much better
no that was herbal so we gotta keep that
beat listen Bungie has truth we only
love what they do we just want to see
them commit to that low but I think they
are based on the transparency look I
think you hit the nail on the head on
that and if it does look who I mean
we're all be running for it Oh
yeah it's like if it's worthwhile
somebody in chat said it we said it
before I've been working on solo
flawless pit of heresy finally finished
that thing up but I was like if there
was any way to earn pieces of armor that
weren't dream bane you know stat pieces
of crap if it was actually like dropping
chunks of armor off of Szolnok and I
look like a freakin fire live night I
would be just like in heaven right I'd
be like dude I will do this every week
it had like no question about it because
I'm gonna walk her in the tower like a
monster like so ya know this is this
stick and the fact that they're doing it
that soon that's really great honestly
I'm super pleased yeah yeah so the next
piece we are improving the rewards and
this is one we actually will have some
questions for you guys we are improving
the rewards for aspirational activities
raids trials and dungeons going forward
aspirational activities will reward
players with power items and vanity when
we build an aspirational activity it
will have at least one accessory to
pursue not entirely sure where you claim
accessory if that's the vanity thing
hopefully the team is working on adept
weapons for trials trials we'll get new
armor aka not reprisal so a brand new
set accessories and weapons in season 13
trials will get new armor every year
duskies new raid armor will have new
raid will have brand new armor weapons
and exotics accessories to pursue no
spoilers so first piece is going forward
aspirational activities will reward
players with with power items and vanity
I think we probably all agree that one's
pretty good
surely go wrong now here's here's the
trial stuff this is where I want to ask
you guys we are currently in season 10
season 11 is the summer season 12 the
fall expansion season 13 you can picture
that one as December ish yeah trials
will get new armor accessories and
weapons in season 13 so trials is not
gonna get new armor new weapons or
accessories for six months just to put a
timeframe on it they are working in the
Adept weapons probably for a similar
timeframe as well how do you guys feel
about that
yes yeah I'll jump in I was honestly
letting it soak up a little bit but um
that's a tough one I mean honestly I'm
willing to wait on some of the cosmetic
slush weapons stuff as long as we fixed
the issues correctly bridge so if we get
old if we can get a good handle on the
cheating scene if we can get a good
handle on the error codes because
they're still happening if all yeah we
can be it
you know if we can get a good handle on
incentivizing like so in terms of like I
mean I know like no part of
incentivizing is new weapons and your
armors I get it but I just mean like in
generally not incentivizing people to
token farm the three wins breathe like
so like really making it very worthwhile
going flawless season even if that means
like right now flawless doesn't mean an
in depth weapon if it means three
ascended charts but I don't know that's
just spitballing so just whatever it's
just like in a in a gigantic bucket of
tokens of tokens like whatever it takes
like if they can just get the the
structure of it right where then all
they have to do is plop the weapons and
the armor into it if they're popping
that into a working trials I'm fine
we jump right in man Steve you got me on
it I'm so itchy brother I'm so with you
because I II I know where you're going
no I'm s
that's the other side so he's asking a
fantastic question that's what a
fantastic um I think my thing with
bungee in the past has always been I
don't have a problem with waiting as
long as you are transparent when they do
stuff like this that eases the blow
right you do set the expectation okay
guys this is the reality and we jet
finish coming off saying hey resources
alone cuz we all know what I think
they've not gonna always say that far
but behind the scenes we know what's
going on so the fact that they're doing
it though like I'm super impressed
because to be honest like I didn't think
I'm a huge pile of trials that's just my
heart you know
shut up to the Warlocks out there what's
your favorite armor if Ares would stop
messing up my six winned car Ares if you
in there maybe I can get the office go
play somewhere else you'll run into him
in a riot listen mister D I've got no
cheese that's the only reason why I'm
over there
I know it's thick yeah anyway the whole
thing is look a damn weapons a copy you
know saying that that was my heart
reward that that high level stuff you
know as far as you know adding every
year I was surprised and we gonna get a
new said that is that is a resource
commitment y'all yeah no mistake he's
got all that other stuffs going away
that's true but I still like the fat
from a creative stamp ya know we could
get some cool in the good thing is to is
at least you'll be able to take those
Charles weapons and the normal crucible
and at networking comp too it'll it'll
transfer into something like maybe not
trials but you'll still be able to use
in some places yeah yeah this is cool
Matt I like these goals I think yes I
was gonna say I agree do cognate another
big thing too is just I'm liking the
standard that they're setting for these
twelves right now because the level of
like you said transparency in the level
of communication if this is something
that we can
keep up rollin like in it doesn't mean
like every single club having like a
kabillion features that I love but just
keeping us in the loop you know I'm
gonna be okay like and you know like
we're at we're at this we don't quite
yet have this done yet but we're getting
there like you know and just instead of
just having us in the dark and then when
they do
plop something into the game it's not we
want because they didn't tell us for six
months yeah we might have been able to
say something four months back where
they could have made a change but now
it's great to make a change so exciting
I do think that um that a lot of this is
is good and just for one quick example
the trials rotation that God mentioned
we found out that trials was rotating we
we were able to give feedback and it got
changed without even even being a week
right like you know in that Connect that
that that type of stuff is is something
that I'm looking forward to in the
future of a bungee being able to have
that dev to player group relationship
yeah let's be honest I know as much as
we give sometimes we give bungee crap a
lot of the community does let's just say
that you know I gotta admit I I'm old
I've been gaming a long time I have not
seen a company with this level of
transparency with their community on a
weekly basis I've been around a lot of
games most most companies developers
don't let you in behind the scenes
behind the curtain messages why things
are taken long that's why I appreciate
when it loops months if doesn't
director's cut like you really get in
the feel and the feedback of the studio
right yeah it's rare gems man so again
salute to them on this because I'm with
you see me in a sense that yeah well
I've liked it to be
you know quicker absolutely later at the
end of the day even if it's a
transitionary thing we're okay we're
gonna wait till season 13 or whatever it
is right but in between then like you
said maybe shards get introduced wipe
the floor let's and what do you think I
most advocate or maybe pop in the old
trials the nine weapons revamp them I
don't know just just experiment just
experiment assets and stuff like that so
yeah I think it will be a gradual thing
of them tweaking tweaking until they get
to their ultimate goal but ultimately II
I think um I think this is really cool I
was surprised to see this is a huge
commitment to something I didn't think
they would get in front of that's what I
meant
well yeah he what was your feeling when
you would you see honestly it's like I
mean as I'm less of a PvP player I was
more curious about the reaction from
some if people take like the take a
second and think about you know what
they are committing to if they take the
second and think about what seabees
saying for hey if they fix the cheating
if they fix the mode if they fix the
flawless just being valuable all those
things are working properly if you dump
another set of like weapons in like in
season 11 you're like oh same crap same
you know three ruined token farming and
all that stuff that doesn't feel as
rewarding as in agreeing picks the other
stuff now then the rewards have you an
even better feel later if people take
just a second realize that's perfect
like it's just a point of people like
hey I'm gonna do trials all the season
I'm grinded up so much I'm helping
people get there
I got another six months of the same
weapons and armor hmm like I depth some
people will have that reaction so I was
on its agenda that's fair no it's fair
and that's yeah though no and that's why
I was kind of wanting to see what you
guys would say is definitely more PvP
PvE and yeah I'm somewhere in the middle
of that I am feels like I'll I haven't
done trials but like a tiny bit but it
was like definitely more PvE but I like
when I read that it was like I could see
some people having an issue but the way
you phrased it is perfect if the
patience is there I think the payoff was
gonna be much better again yeah what
else we got big thing in bold beginning
in season 12 we will no longer be
selling ships go shells sparrows or
armor ornaments in ever verse that are
visually based on themes from
aspirational activities we just talked
about this but like dungeon armor
dungeon ships or all those things we've
just mentioned like we are not planning
on changing existing items as at this
time as we could be spending time on
item item for the features so season 11
outside of the one changes I mentioned
probably gonna stay as is but knowing in
the fourth like beginning in season 12
if there's a pyramid ship raid who knows
but whatever that stuff you're gonna be
able to earn all the cosmetic things
that go at that the ship the sparrow the
ghost that's that's huge like I mean I
just even think about that level of time
people spent in shattered to get the
ship and ascended challenge to get the
it's just crazy like what even one small
cosmetic can do for an activity and so
I'm really like I mean it doesn't even
always have to be a weapon that's been
proven
like I mean we've seen it read me all
the way down to outbreak everybody going
for nano Phoenix ratio I still every
wants to wall jump in there I'm like why
get it this time it's only been six
years no come back and try it again but
uh but yeah all the way down to back
then like it's always held true that you
know like they with the right incentive
I mean people will keep playing things
Rach April
I mean come on this is I suppose my
heart great I went on a rant latter
video I went on the last brick last word
read last week
yes about this it's so crazy to see it
come back so fast I mean it's got to the
point CB whiz like I now when I'm in a
fireteam yeah I'll rock my platinum
Starling um the the aren't know what you
are the black I know so many people you
know having God it's like a badge of
honor that's like my dad we labs ghost
showcase this that's the destiny I miss
right now just havin knows those those
visual cues that IRA never for you
either going into the tower or you're
sitting in orbit be like yo how did you
get there I remember going up to other
God where did you get it
Iran such a such ban Iran 75 for Jews as
opposed to yeah I bought that it's such
a disparity so yeah I love this change
because like I stressed last week
ornaments all this stuff ships arm
that's Luke - no it is no it is agreed
and an attached to the right thing will
grind it over and over I have still
everyone snow all gone back to wrap the
machine just thinking that it might be
the time it hasn't bear
I still don't have any know somebody
Flay that switch to your the dungeon the
soloist like how does this make you feel
that you could be ending up looking like
soul man you could be getting a shadow
that's looking like a garden here like
that's the idea because like I mean d1
had this stuff you had the saber strike
you had that thing for the warlocks you
had the dark blade skull for the Titans
was so those were things they had before
like that's when you're like all into
that like this straight
dude I might actually get this cool
thing like there was incentive again as
you're saying it's been back there why
we've been waiting some for some reason
sometimes this long to get some of this
stuff but yeah it's like soloing
shattered throne like I'm literally
shaking my blood pressure is probably at
like 180 like when I'm doing a couple of
these things whether it's the totem
fight in pit of heresy like soloing that
things
yikes when you're doing the golgoroth
fight or the Borg a fight in a shattered
throne yeah both of those those like you
know I've got it down to this thing I'm
using the bow whittle and all these
wizards when I get done with those
places I want to walk out of there with
more than a freaking emblem I'm I'm
honestly tired of emblems being every 3h
like emblems have been so many things
and it's like finally we got the ghost
with Guardian games and I was like this
is like actually a small token of like a
glimmer of hope with a ghost and then
now we see this was like they're making
strides in a proper direction to reward
you for the time you put into the game
and this just continues to say they're
gonna stick with it which is good don't
I completely agree Wilson my next big
Peace Corps playlist reward changes
strikes gambit and crucible we are
adding a new set of armor for the Corps
playlist strikes gambit and crucible the
armor shares a new set of G a set of new
geometry with decals and shaders
specific to the activity we will create
new sets of armor like this each year
examples year for
your five your six etc this set will
arrive alongside the next expansion
though each all expansion is going to
get a set of armor for strikes gambit
crucible
it was just a KA like a vendor refresh I
was trying to amass you yes yeah I got a
thank you mark oh yeah yeah I'm
wondering if like we're gonna be able to
get like a maybe a normal set from the
vendors and then maybe like random drops
as we do the activities or something
with different stat rolls I'm trying to
like envision how that's gonna work but
I'm happy about it I definitely want to
refresh regardless I'm at school stuff
like kognito set before something that
looks cool yeah I just like the way they
phrased it's a new set of geometry it's
not yeah here's this thing with like a
slight texture difference here but it's
the exact same thing it's like it's a
new grilles yeah yeah but they've got
decals and shaders specific so you're
gonna have like the core playlist I
think they're gonna get you a set of
armor for all free potentially mmm but
they're you're gonna have shaders and
they say decals which is a weird way for
them to phrase it that's like a decals
like a sticker but like I picture that
as more of like is it gonna be an
ornament for it not sure that was my
interpretation what do you what do you
think of me I'm thinking possibly um you
know I like gambit each activity kind of
has like a and emblem like this for
gambit yes thanks for Gambon and the
bird kind of thing for one card have to
be you know same kind of thing crucible
so yeah I mean it's interesting I mean
shout out to game begins well locks
didn't gambit armor I'm not putting that
on I I like what they're doing though
because I think they're like it's it's
all fitting into a bigger puzzle where
they're trying to make these activities
more worth it and so one thing that they
did before that was adding the plus ones
like I mean it's like strikes dead like
once there was like you couldn't even
get above a thousand what strikes me
more and there was no specific look for
them and like like they they kind of
like there was no point in doing them
back in and so like I'm liking that
they're building like reason to do these
activities plus ones back
refreshes the flute-like hopefully
eventually some exclusive stuff per
certain activities like if they keep
like slowly building these these puzzles
like there's gonna be a lot of I mean
there was so many people in d1 that's
what's been a whole day running straight
Oh breach hold it I still call it yes I
said a whole day trying to get him on
the loop got a whole day a whole day
trying to get that grasp makes a I'm
really really excited for where like
this could go like it's too early but
it's it's all positive
in my opinion super positive because
again these are the core activities
these are the things that we are going
to grind consistently but if you like
like see you say if you give that
incentive and you give cool rewards as a
result whether it be you know cosmetic
or whatever the coop the community has
shown we will run this stuff or Zildjian
ties we will do it this stuff exactly
there's stuff to be had we will do again
very very cool yep whether it's decal
shaders ornaments who knows but all of
that each expansion we get one which is
pretty cool also starting in season 12
which is year four if you guys need to
keep all that's where we are adding a
new pursuit weapon each season this
weapon can be earned by playing your
preferred core playlist so that is
strikes gambit or crucible so you can
get it from any of them this weapon will
have activity specific legendary skins
that can be unlocked in each playlist so
you'll be able to earn the weapon by any
basic activity I think it would
basically be the way
hey here's Ariana's vow to get this
catalyst you need to run 400 of all the
basic activities it's probably gonna be
something similar I would imagine and
then you've got a skin if you like hey I
love strikes you're probably gonna get
that skin or ornament the unlocks to
make this thing be more of the strike
look or I play in crapload of crucible
hey I've got the crucible ornament to
slap on it so everybody's gonna have
access to this one weapon but you're
gonna have a way to customize personally
your look in whatever you play for those
who love gambit whoever you are
you'll be able to put that on there too
I wanted to get them yeah go ahead bad
question no I'm confused maybe I'm
reading room when I read pursuit weapon
are we kind of yes
I and that was when I've read the 12 on
my stream yesterday it seemed like we
were getting some some mixed kind of
feedback on that line all right because
because if that does replace ritual that
would probably mean that potentially the
new going forward is gonna be instead of
three weapons probably one that looks
different depending on the activity you
do know that's what it seems like at
least yep and so it's an interesting
thing they I guess the only reason why
I'm questioning is that prior 12 right
we see they they explained why they were
going away from it and they were like
how you know somebody's Legendary's
became too strong in a way right and
then you know so they basically went
from what was it was a ritual to I
forgot the beam they were rich oh right
so now we're pursuit yeah so I guess I'm
just listen I'm happy they're coming
don't get me wrong I'm I'm confused
because I thought they were fighting
this so I just wanted to bring it back
to you guys later
how yeah yeah I think it's all cause and
effect I feel like I'm it sounds like
they're worried I mean they don't want
to lock themselves into three weapons a
season it must be it must be too rich it
must be too rigorous from to make three
extra weapons that are all good and
actually worth it or else I don't see
why they would navigate away from ritual
um that just seems to be my initial CCB
so you think it's one per season as
opposed to three perhaps that's what I'm
thinking and I'm hoping if that was to
be the case cuz I think we can all agree
that rituals were okay but it's not like
they were game changing yeah let's hope
that that if it we ever having a pursuit
weapon instead of rituals I'm hoping
that it will at least be in between
pinnacle and ritual any better than our
ritual weapons so that if we're getting
three like and like not bad like you
know this plate thought was pretty good
at I want to
I think it was a great option for people
if they need a one-two punch shotgun but
it also didn't break the game right you
know the way like a recluse or
mountaintop Twitter some yeah so if they
are gonna want themselves to one every
season then maybe it can be they can
boost it up a little bit maybe a little
bit so maybe they'll be able to play
around with how good these weapons are
if they do it this way and you'll be
less dev stress yeah I don't know that
best us all like theories yeah that
could be what do you think ma'am me uh I
guess it all honestly depends on what
else we get based on each season like
the expansions obviously drop a decent
chunk of weapons the seasons have been
smaller but I mean we how many weapons
did we have in Sunday in season of Dawn
we had I mean between the obelisks and
and then the tower of us we had like ten
this time around we had like or five
burn I was like it'd be nice to make it
so I guess we if we're only getting one
maybe as abuse and it does have that
like squeak more performance so it's
just a small tear above that hey you got
to go run a hundred activities it's like
damn that's gonna be a while but when
you do get said thing it's gonna be just
a little bit better which is a nice a
nice payoff at least for your investment
yeah I like how you can get the skin and
make it be like hey I'm on the pde guy
or run strikes like crazy guess what you
can slap a PB you skin on it support
your PBS that the one has to be tied
into what we get each season if I get
three weapons if I get three weapons in
a season from this activity and we get
three weapons and entire season I only
get one more I'm like that's not enough
but if we're getting like ten that I'm
like you got one more school so it's
like it's the balance of what is the
seasonal offering versus the one pursuit
because if you're taken away to
potentially you know ritual I'm gonna
get those names confused too it's like
it's like you know I would like one of
each weapon like every see every season
potentially because you know submachine
gun shotgun stuff like that not
everybody plays the same way not
everything is always in the season
that's true all that tiny stuff so so
it's the balance of though they'll get
sprinkled in other places as hopefully
we'll see like that
first in other places hopefully the
Stanhope my only my only caveat to is
that if it is the one I love the aspect
the Highlander of weapons I love the
aspect of being specific like a new perk
created now I know you'll say hey yeah I
know that's what made recluse and all
this stuff kind of cool right you know
I'll see you know what if arms stuff and
and my thing is the reason why I'm just
bringing it I'm justifying it is because
with you be happy with weaponry
detriment right yeah mount happen all
that stuff is gonna go right now hundred
percent right so that's how you can kind
of control it and rein it in you know if
it did get out of trouble so you know to
get a passionate gonna tweak they're
gonna do that stuff yeah I think them an
opportunity because I would be honest
y'all when rituals came out I mean yes
Python was cool but what was that what's
the SMG in Gambia
I love those specific new perks
even with rhetorics you know a head bows
the arm the one that makes it spin up
super fast when you get the the
precision kill desperado yeah like I
love stuff like that just you know it's
cool again because of weapon retirement
I feel it's a nice opportunity to bring
it back but we'll see that's just me
being green that's only yeah we uh I saw
that Elsa went to yeah scream just went
down for a second awesome yeah it's just
trying to come back up real quick should
be attempting to reconnect here we go
coming back come on back okay it was
like was something that's a look at the
core my I was like oh
perk I was talked about you agreed
everything you said and hopefully I mean
either they can do that where it's like
a unique perk or at least hopefully they
can maybe make it where they have small
little performance boosts in the certain
avenues of the activities perform better
so then maybe at least you have an
incentive to use them in in said
activities you get a 600 Auto rifle that
has you know a bit more range and a bit
more reload speed than most anything
else out there that sets it apart some
way to set it apart is what you're going
for be in a specific perk which I do
like the idea because that really is
like hey this thing performs at least in
a unique way as opposed yeah here's this
little bump and range and stability whoo
it's like some people don't even like
feel that type of stuff you wanna yeah
you want to see a performance a slightly
different way so mmm I agree a final
piece that Luke Smith touched on was
dust and engrams but they said we're
making it easier for you to earn bright
dust we'll be moving away from character
specific ways to earn bright dust and
more toward account specific paths this
change is geared toward one character
player significantly significantly more
bright dust than they earned today which
they've mentioned this a couple times
now because you've got players like us
who probably play all three characters I
have one inch we do we play a lot they
split everything I've got a decent
amount of stuff then you have the person
who's like I'm a Titan I have one I've
got you know four or five hours a week
to play we had you know Captain McFly on
here he gets like three hours a week
like or like couple hours three days a
week to play so like in six hours a week
he's not gonna be able to burn through
three characters you know giving them a
chance to earn more overall being pretty
good and I thought they already started
like experimenting pretty well with that
in incorporating the bright dust into
the Guardian games bounties I was I
didn't even realize how much I was
earning it tells like oh and like I was
actually able to like purchase some
stuff in in the actual like yeah I mean
ever first no surprised I'm not used to
having bright dust that I really liked
that I was like this is this feels good
running these bounties trying to get
heir-apparent than I look and I'm like
oh 8,000 right dust I'm like wow that's
a lot of break that's a lot of bright
dust and so it I hope that that
continues to be the case where it's like
all right I just grinded
you know by eight hours this game
hopefully like my break dust will start
reflecting the amount of hours I'm
putting in so I think it's all good all
good stuff
well said man yeah this this is all good
you know we want that the respect of the
time commitment and like you said you
know when you when you're doing these
bounties and doing this grind to get
that practice to be able to reward
yourself with a cool cosmetic as to as
opposed to always don't forget the
checkbook the credit card people who
like live in your game word of what like
I mean come on you got like thousands of
hours in here it's like if I've got
thousands of hours of the game I
probably told her that people will get
out the game I'm streaming about it I'm
trying to get other people in your world
or doesn't you're trying to do that
that's that's a general nice thing to do
finally thing they're updating the
Brighton gram to be more relevant than
it is today the Brighton gram in the
season pass will be updated to include
various year three ever verse items
previously sold for silver and bright
dust going forward the bright and Graham
will update each season to include ever
versed items 3 plus seasons prior story
is gonna be about 9 months at behind
forever verse for that bright end gram
so anything you may have missed you'll
start catching up on a little more of
the relevant stuff you guys even care
about this one I've been getting like I
swear I'm working on like my year 1 or
year 2 tab right now with all those yeah
I'm patient so I'm honestly ok with this
about a 10 nine months rolls around I'll
I'll go if I saw something I'll go take
a peek and go look and get a Snagit oh
boy I'm off way too bad there's a lot of
snot a lot of stuff that I missed out
when I switched over the PC cuz I
switched accounts oh ok God you see so
some stuff a lot and I miss certain
ornaments be hard like with the shiny
yes
that's like the white colored one almost
right the shiny guys
oh yeah I love the opportunity to be
able to get that stuff back yeah mm-hmm
I mean that wraps up everything
basically Luke said as for the twelve it
does go over I'm just gonna open this
back up in a second covered Guardian
games Titans basically have won the
thing shoutouts of warlocks on hunters
if one of you takes one of these days
before this thing is you will be in
second place so all the Titans can you
guys like take one day off and give
warlocks at just one go give warlocks
one that were the hunters can have their
brats because I'm sorry that hunter
cloak looks good in all three but the
silver on your arm looks pretty solid
yeah I like a rock with this ooh I'll
take good and then the Guardian heart
charity it is wrapping up on Tuesday
basically a weekly reset if you guys
haven't seen the Guardian heart charity
all their efforts they passed 700
thousand there over 750 thousand right
now which is just insane every 20 bucks
community so amazing as we've talked
about to till we're blue in the face in
the beginning of this podcast there are
a few Bungie bounties left here if you
are still trying if you're in the United
States this one might be early but Zoe
may have actually sent you guys to her
before 5:00 a.m. on PC so that's 7 a.m.
for me 8 a.m. for you guys and then
couple that we know fairly well or at
least I do
may 11th we've got jarv & Hound ish yeah
that's a really cool window yeah so a
couple more Bungie bounties if you want
kind of funny and what's good games were
today at noon so if you missed that one
that was your ps4 last one I'm going to
fami went 1:00 a.m. this morning he did
this morning 1:00 a.m. he is because
he's he's an Australian polar bear were
today at 10:00 and then kind of funny
was at noon the last two is tomorrow
bright in the morning and then the 11th
so it'll be Monday
so not too many opportunities left if
you're trying to get those Bungie bounty
emblems but try and hunt those people
down get up early set that alarm go play
amounts and then of course we've got
iron Manor coming last chance for the
bow last chance for the bow yeah there's
a pretty crispy looking picture of the
bow but yes iron banner and bonus valor
pinnacles if you're going for those but
point of the stag this is your last
chance to get it the weapon will not be
available during season 11 so get in
there who knows you'll maybe fall in
love with the new bow but again I did
want to ask you guys about that this is
one of those things as this actually
made me think of it outside of bugs and
Eric hoes you guys can read that stuff
but that's most of the table when it
comes to things like Ariana's Val when
are is that stuff gonna come back into
the game because people who don't have
Ariana's Val right now Grand Master
nightfalls are without that weapon yeah
no I agree
um it's that's a tough one I mean I
think that the natural like answer would
be the like the next big deal see but is
that too long when a certain weapons
becomes meta and then if person feels
locked out but one thing I mean I do
think that if I take a guess the weapons
that are obviously alike now so Tommy's
matchbook Arianna's all those I think
will be available in September but then
I think going forward after that when we
start getting weapons similar to Ariane
this Val I don't think it's they're ever
gonna go away because they were kind of
mentioning trying to get away from the
FOMO III so I think that this might go
on one more season possibly I don't
think they're gonna drop next season cuz
I think we're gonna get a new area on
his pal next season in season 11 but I I
do think that after season 12 we'll stop
having that issue but it might just be
one of the pains just to wait out until
September possibly would you take I mean
that's what I'd like to see obviously
season 11 of area on this isn't their
conker is gonna be tough for some people
because yeah for barrier and rain and
part of this is just the way we have the
artifact right now the barriers are so
close range if we get back to say light
pulses or Scouts or something where you
can work a little farther away we'll
have some more options which would be
nice right
all of this would still not be an issue
cross my fingers I'm gonna probably say
it every podcast you know where I'm
going if you can get a sock
slot on a mod slot on exotics the would
solve this whole issue because be like
oh I need other options that's just
gonna open more things up I don't know
if they're worried it's gonna take away
from the current season weapons but the
new people who don't even have access to
those don't get some random drops but
they can't use them they gotta be give
some more value and life back into those
though yeah I think hopefully in season
12 that is something they've got to work
on I've heard too many not just us I've
heard too many people mention that
hopefully that it's gotta be I mean yeah
it's so funny how has it happened so
again you know when I when I hate him
but I hate him not talk about it I
always always feel like they are
concerned about that's how I always feel
they are like that's what it through
it's a slippery slope they don't want to
make everything useless and they don't
want to make weapons that people aren't
gonna use so it's tough because I do I
hear you abundance on it too and then
cuz it also it might be cool it might
make some exotics that don't get played
maybe play a little bit more so it could
it could also help some other exotic
stop dominating other exotics who knows
but like it but there's all those things
the way like it's it's just it's one of
those tough things I'm sure that they
they've thought about but I'm sure it
would be there if they weren't scared or
if it was gonna break the game at this
minute let me standpoint maybe alter in
exotics I don't know because I wish is
done it's done bad yeah I stopped
because this is what we have exotic cut
roles like in terms of perks they just
need to be tough it just you know I just
it's it's tough it's a tough tell like
my examples like what was season 1 like
was pulse rifles or something like that
I'm like whatever pulled graviton Lance
out instead for a pulse and I could anti
barriers I love it that's a point where
I don't think I don't think that breaks
the game because literally the function
if they think the gun itself does
balance like if I go into a game with
graviton Lance and you're like that one
cosmology explosion doesn't break the
game then all I'm saying is I want to
use that on a barrier guy instead and
then I still function the same way
that's why I was like I'm with you I
know you are I'm just that's why I was
like that's why I keep saying it every
time hopefully somebody out there hears
it cuz that's why I see bees maybe like
I think it has to be something from the
technical side on the back end to either
I don't know if it's just really
difficult to do or to implement
you know saying but it's gotta be
something because they just talking
about it they just said put a mod slot
on every piece of armor they put in the
game all those seasonal pieces of armor
that like all the faction ones like they
added slots to like ten and they could
even take an exotic weapon and say hey
all it can take is the seasonal mods you
can't put backup mag or rampage or
anything like that on there all it can
take is this easel mod but at least you
could use them so I'll shut up now get
off my cellphone honestly no I mean it's
not a bad point it's something that I
hope that they at least wait and see cuz
it could be interesting I mean it would
be cool if you could you know make
graviton Lancer overloads let's wake
vigil and swing any barriers you never
know yeah so I'm saying it is at least
an interesting thought like I you know
it's we'll see I would love to use
racking oh yeah yeah but running again
like see all these feel like there's so
many exotics they're not being utilized
because literally if you're gonna go to
that content they're throwing these
champions into everything that we're
typically in a face especially if they
talk about aspirational content but then
you have this load of exotics that we
can't use so it's just a weird mixed
right now yeah
maybe it maybe its expansion maybe it's
something like we're gonna just requires
more time and generally those bigger
kind of changes let's be real
when expansion is we get it it's also
like a huge change of life everything's
mansion they always do some into the
game that really affects its core so
maybe it's one of those things that they
can do and it just takes longer so
they've pushed that down into that zone
and we always get surprised every
experience we get oh wow they're doing
this what is what are you okay what
would you guys like when it comes to the
fall expansion what is your like what is
the major fix is it a weapons 2.0 is it
Armour 3.0 is it I know we've had a lot
of good wins today but is there any
current function you know strike
specific glute like what do you guys
feel really yeah basically on a higher
skill though just trying to make some of
the activities that have struggled to
have value just trying to bring the
value back so that that can apply to
trials I can apply to strikes that can
apply to read say it just blanket just
trying to bring point back into
activities I think is like one of the
big things we're getting the mud started
there started be interesting we're
starting to have customization same
thing with our what excuse me with with
the armor and weapons so the except for
the exotics obviously don't have the
exotics but if so like they're starting
to like we're starting to have
interesting combos we can try but if we
could get some of these activities
playable and and rewarding
same thing with Grandmaster Naples to
even boostin knows a little bit more so
people were in those for more than just
Conqueror like if they can just put a
blanket like adding value to a lot of
the activities that would be my
slam-dunk in September for me yeah
literally literally on the same page I
mean I'm such a proponent for raids and
I don't think they get enough credit or
how great they are and and how unique
they are to the 8th you know I'm all
about incentivizing all about always
having like a pinnacle activity raid
rotate a list because one thing is my
MRSA under his stat you know you got
third than as beautiful as the last wish
and no one's not running it no more
right now but if you incentivize say yo
this week
wish you guys could get pinnacles in
there that it just drives a hundred a
hundred percent and I think that that's
something that they got a hundred
percent right in destiny one started
rotating they brought all the great
ornaments they are rotating that was
that one of the best points in terms of
rating experience trying to triumph in a
certain reason think about how cool like
you did bears Titans aren't so bad after
Wi-Fi helmet did crow tu you out coming
out outfitted it looking like Oryx like
oh let's it was their best ornaments -
Oh gorgeous for sure yeah in so let that
that would be huge you made a great
point the rotating raids back would be
awesome and and they already at least
set a few things I know about the twelve
what was the line they said I'm honest
up earlier in today's twin yesterday's
twelve when it was the line he said
about rates can you repeat what they had
said if you scroll back up to the top I
think I was hanging from of the geometry
oh no not the geometry they did just
mention some on board aspiration
austerities will reward players power
items and vanity that art so so I do it
so if they can get this so the two
things for me so I just wanted to say so
one if they can make the old raids
replayable and if they can just make
raids in general more rewarding oppose
me to think so if they already touching
a little bit I'm trying to make it more
rewarding so if they can also I'm with
you I would love if every blue moon if
spires stars as a powerful imma go have
a blast from the past day of our stars
and get a powerful thing out of it yeah
please do drop rates of a little Anarchy
low 1k last wish well guess what
anarchy drop rates are buffed and you
can get a pinnacle if you finished you
know the heart run or whatever it's like
and then you're gonna have people be
like hey I gotta figure out these raids
again cuz there's actually a reason to
do the old ones that would be huge that
would I completely agree with for you
guys that one's huge is the rewarding
and the other piece Prescott said and
this is one I've thought about too
they've teased this already the obelisks
and things of that nature would make the
vendors like the obelisks have been be
like have a way to level those up with
late spending your time and the strikes
you level up to follow to like hey level
10 you unlocked a new mod or you unlock
and have some long-term engagement stuff
at those cuz right now I could turn in
4000 tokens to the crucible guy and it
doesn't mean a damn bit of anything and
that used to be really cool destiny 1/2
the packages system when you turn in
packages to the crucible in in to the
vanguard and you know you might get a
crazy crazy palindrome or something like
it was just there was really cool stuff
with the people with the turning into
vendors I agree I would love at vendors
remember got an exotic class item mark
yeah that was amazing - it's just those
little things that you wouldn't think
would change the gaming experience but
there are people grinding all of those
class items on all characters I know I
had mine
so yeah I'm with you would inspect
something like how do they have an
exciting that's like and then then you
go do your research you go looking like
alright well I need to start my bite you
know my journey on getting this new dead
orbit weren't so shot out with my man
dane in the chat dangle and he says make
old weapons yeah random rolls I'm with
that man because again like it adds a
ball flavor to some of them could you
imagine you know you have a random roll
you know uh weapons that baby didn't get
in and now you're Ella dresser I mean no
you're just a midnight coup almost
probably you're good they're only gonna
get worse but still yes well maybe they
can smoothly maybe The Conspirator
they're right cuz they're nothing spirit
spirit ER or the what's the auto the
autos DM oh yeah I forget those Primus
ghosts yes ghost Primus yeah it's like
cuz in the auto realm
rifleman and I was kind of saying that
same thing with making strikes viable to
again yeah with them making like let's
say what if they duty-bound control
random again yeah I mean in this Auto
ready running duty bones another basic
scrap so good great point keV like cuz
that's yes that's huge like this stuff
that's huge
yeah because think about it right now
we're getting interference back in with
new perks
we're getting last hope now with young
you know killed mug feeding frenzy in
the hill yeah it's crazy rolls of old
weapons that we used too low so I would
love that mindset to be applied to the
race because this beyond it's like a lot
of the rate but aside from a few
standouts here in their per area and the
exotics of course you don't say a lot of
the rate Lou kind of feels jinair 100%
of Korean like even just take like an
example of like I believe in Argos where
the grenade launcher could drop if that
could I've dropped with spike nades back
when spike maids were like early like
super meadow with like swarming peeper
like once form of the rape and heard
people want to win to go and you can go
into Argos and grindin awesome in then
we'd be playing raids to Deline specific
checkpoints in activities in the raid
you know a good role reversal
which in so and I want them to take the
same love in PvE because I want them
doing PvE
I would love us they could sprinkle them
into the trials of the nine weapons
being written rolled in PvP because some
of those are still beast to without good
rolls thanks to some of those pulse
rifles like Rick like I know relentless
and I think there's one other one I'm
trying to remember but but they're
already good with not even great perks
and so if they can show that same love
on both sides of the spectrum I mean
naked really getting it right back I
would love a guy's eye I see dude
duty-bound like you said he yeah it is
like badass 600 so nice right back they
just love random roles 600 from the raid
or subtype till nightfall activity 100%
let me grind a got rule DFA or something
that that's one of my favorite weapons
in the game I still love it did not
happen so yeah yeah but that's like the
other way yeah that's that's pretty much
all they've got for the 12 this week
there anything else you guys want to
cover for topics I know we kind of
actually do have one for you see be gray
we've asked this to some guests I feel
like I've fallen off of it a few times
but before your history of destinies
were getting ready to capstone about six
years into
and I want top three just moments in the
game itself for you we've gone away from
it good question yep moments in the game
oh my god not like making a video but
gameplay moments for you that are just
like
chef's kiss or some moments with some
destiny moment but into this moments
like so in like it I'm playing the game
and I have a moment with in something
but so like what am i all use I'll give
you one of mine for my examples when my
buddy and I one of my best friends we -
man Dakota and it was like we practiced
for like a couple hours we just like
whole damn thing and that was our
flawless right - so like - man flawless
card out it was like that's one of mine
that we'll always stick with me so
that's just an example so what are your
like just epic moments for you just
three doesn't have to be like the
craziest thing but yeah um so one like I
still gotta put like one of my first
voting loss experiences in there was
something that I always remember yeah
well welcome every time this is really
tough for me to cap it to 3 I mean if
you just keep saying I will go with it
but yeah man my capping at the 3 um yeah
like I'll put the vault in there and
then and oh yeah like my my first
fullest and yes anyone was also a very
great man
I'd house action ended by delay there's
like that it's tough like there's
there's a moment in game 2 that will
always be one of my favorite moments
that like wasn't even an activity but
was like where we brought the whole
community together in the tower where
like we had a gigantic like tower such
for a song that I made and made a whole
music video in the tower coordinated
dance in this tower that dry some
crimson days ain't just bringing
everybody together and working together
was still probably one of my favorite
moments just saying everybody together
and making a like um like more or less
it's like I'm music on the tower it's
definitely another month within man but
then Niobe laughs was a really fun
moment to stay and you got him that's
big and then that's that's that's for
that I mentioned yeah I got a I got a
put in honorable mention to my first 35
Scholl lost - that was a time there's
games yes there's too many times overall
and all I love the game too much to put
it that's always hard to do 3 but that's
the it was good a bunch of spot on that
one but yes
I really really it's hard as there's a
hard heart that's a good way of a solid
list yeah and you're like huh
it knows gonna be under so much pressure
so what got you guys into what got you
guys into starting content creation like
what made you want to take destiny from
just playing destiny to doing what you
guys knew now are you you bring people
on you're talking about the game talking
about the state of the game helping
people out as well and really just what
made it want to be from I'm playing the
game too now I am streaming slash making
videos slash making podcast and all of
the other stuff that comes with what we
all do is podcast we can blame for
Guardian con for nearly 17 right we met
both of these two I'll keep the language
decent both of us who were out there in
the swamp sweat and hath sent out
business cards for the crazy people in
lying a Tampa Fairgrounds get bumping
into each other around there and they
just kind of kept in touch and then some
reason we're dumb enough to start a
podcaster and curse of Osiris so I like
that that was just like when we knew
it's like hey do you yeah during sure
what like all all of those times were
ridiculous that's what the podcast at
least came from me and I'd probably say
you're probably pretty close there
as for the content creation for me
probably kind of said it a little bit
earlier but just like the wanting to
I've watched other people make it so
much I had a point where I had a break
that I took that I thought I could try
and it's just one of those games that I
had I had lived and breathed it enough
and I knew I was decent enough and I
didn't like I had worked through these
challenges myself and I was just like if
I can do these myself can I actually
record myself figure out all the process
and self teach OBS and recording and
capture cards and all the crazy stuff
I'm like this can be done I'm a techie
smart kind of smart dude and I'm just
like I'll see if I can give this thing a
shot and I was just like the first video
putting up and then like division to
division was coming out around the same
time trying to cover both of those
that was about when I started was like
the and how well how long goes up I
started one of my four plus now because
it would have been when Division one
came out that was probably about four
months into my channel so whatever that
year is it's probably so there's a
little bit more than that those does
have to be more than four Division one
came I was a freshman in college and now
I'm over two years out it came out a
while ago I remember when it came out
there's one March 8th of 2016 when 2016
2016
have I been that's what I win do it this
fella know then I was then I was a
junior then that play a demo when it
went the first trailer come on maybe the
day I came out back that no I guess I
was a junior in college when it came on
I don't know why I thought her who knows
but that very very cool
yeah I'm four years in an and June Boyer
say what about shoe Cognito Oh only hear
me
obviously he said the podcasting that
was you know my first Guardian conned
you know again shout out to Tempe the
fairgrounds hot you know no AC we out
there you know you just networking and
me and he hit it off at medium but he
knows I never met someone with a same
amount of passion I have for the game
yeah so that was the start of that and I
didn't care that it was at its lowest
point because I love the game so much
and I just love talking about the game
yeah so you know the weekly updates that
kind of stuff and then it ain't on it
fed into what we are now as far as you
know my channel obviously iron loss
podcast you can't put it together that
day and start from destiny like most
people I go you know you guys were a
destiny podcast at initially we were we
were actually destiny only at one point
you know we first started out shot at
the attic shout out to those guys King
ass off and um I think what ended up
happening was people like we had a
community that loved when we talk about
dusty and there's people like oh my god
you're still talking about that game
transitioned into last word so I could
have my fix still talk and I can just
still talk only about destiny whereas
I'll or podcast kind of evolved into a
multi-platform yeah kind of a thing so
we talked consoles we talk what's going
on in the industry and stuff like that
we still talk about this yeah but we put
a more
and to go for 100 in anything is very
very respectable and and speaking of
Guardian con 2 for any Vytas no in chat
main a bonus also finally a guardian
calling we we knew of each other before
but we kind of put two and two together
he kind of looked at me I kind of look
just like we did we know yes tell you
guys from experience if you were a shirt
with your name actually kind of works
I'll be honest like I recognize the I
mean the excuse me the logo on his shirt
name I recognize my hair that moment and
so yeah so I'm very grateful to just
I've got this chance that's been but I'm
really cool and we got to continue
talking about more destiny it's always
fun talking about destiny and I think
that overall like to kind of put out a
wrap on the whole destiny thing I mean I
feel like overall we're like in a place
where I think we're right about to be
there like I sir I'm seeing some of the
signs where I think if they just keep
doing what they're doing
keep being transparent like I'm hoping
that we get that home run that I know
that everybody wants like everybody then
today wants destiny to be good like I
mean nobody just enjoys it being bad so
like I mean I really think that like
we're or it's gonna be a when we got
some good stuff coming oh in my opinion
so I'm very very excited to see what
where we're at here in September when or
if that's when or October if they follow
through like shadow keep I'm not sure
what they're gonna do in terms of the
new cadence in terms of they're gonna
stick to October with shadow keeper if
we are we going back to September I know
I'm not really got the flexibility not
beholden to Activision that is true they
have boy and I thought that was
impressive that shadow keep actually got
pushed a little bit yeah based on you
know daddy active we should always
behind yeah think about at this time so
that's the advantage yeah and I also
it's respect like what Abbas was saying
to about your four year five year six I
mean I don't think that was always the
plan I'm sure at one point there was the
whole destiny three thing but it sounds
like they realized they weren't ready
and and nobody wants to see a new game
where the vanilla once again like you
know isn't what it could be so I mean it
sounds like they're trying to take
the necessary steps to make sure that
you know at the end of the day
everything ends up it's gonna be good so
completely agree men agree is it's been
toke minutes once they - thank you again
y'all it's been blue it's been a real
really and thank you to everybody that's
been seriously that's that's watched and
supported me and just in general just
want to say I love everybody so so much
and this community is very very
beautiful and it's that's what really
destiny is why don't I get you today
it's like it's it's not always the game
for like why do they say exactly why I
say why are you still playing there why
you still talking to me guys it's
because of the people one is because the
community like it's it's all beautiful
and there's nothing like that I feel
like that can't be all they am anyway
there's nothing that replicates that so
that's what that's what's really special
about destiny
and that's why I feel like you know
we're not going anywhere but last thing
- I went - you come you know - since
you've been in that's the last question
now I can't want to hold you guys up to
know since we're in the same field -
like did you been to field a lot longer
than me what's what's your favorite part
about working in IT taking away from
desk or one question since we're both 19
I yeah I tea in general there you know
I've been in it for now two years since
March I think for me it's just like the
whole science of how things work on the
back end and then on the client facing
side hoping people and resolving some
one issue who is either stressed or
going through a very you know um
critical you know p1 critical kind of a
situation and yeah that kind of showed
them that they have the trust that we
are gonna resolve the issue to help them
do the process and then to see kind of
like like you with your your Street
right yeah
for example like you know when you do
something for someone and you see them
initially stressed they don't see a way
out and then they get that resolution
and their helpfulness so thankful that
you would transparent through the whole
process and then you knock them to their
endgame yeah that is one of the best
parts of our team you know say is that
really cool so that's where kind of
destiny kind of mirrors it exactly you
know
yeah I mean whether we're helping with
quit with IT or whether it's a homework
problem or whether it's destiny no
matter what it is just seeing that end
result and just saying thanks people
that weren't able to get something
whatever insert in and be able to get
whatever that set thing is is like
helping people was like one of the like
I mean it's a really cool part of this
game in community so though it's all
dope so though it's about brother-sister
well thanks Branson that man I I'm two
years in someone keep on pushing we go
rock out II yeah so I mean honestly
thank you all for coming sir CB grey
Christian with man with the fro the spin
foil hat follow the greatness in here we
had to mess up your hair but damn that
was worth it your community is amazing
and honestly so is the Destiny community
so thank you for bringing your community
sharing them with us and thank you for
joining us for an evening chat by the
campfire sir it was amazing to have you
here and honestly can't thank you enough
so make sure you tell everybody who's
listening to be an audio video because
we're gonna post this everywhere where
they can find you what they're gonna see
when they come find you what's the best
place to get a hold yeah perfect so I'm
just kidding the best place to watch us
is we are on YouTube at CB Gracey bead
and GRA why that's the name of our
YouTube channel we make helpful videos
or sometimes if I want to make some
funny videos but mainly helpful videos
with exotic weapons or anything else
that might require you know certains
guides and then we also daily stream on
YouTube usually six to seven days a week
and then after
we're done with our YouTube streams we
stream over on Twitch once we're done it
twitch.tv slash CB gray and yeah we like
to have fun and laugh at me falling off
cliffs and really poorly I'm a potato
player so it's all this all in good fun
and we just like having a good time so
I'd love to share some work memories and
if you ever need any help we always are
here for you so that's that's where
you'll find me
yeah I look forward to seeing you guys
are all beautiful and I appreciate the
time I really do and thank you guys for
having me on the podcast it's really um
it's probably fun talking about destiny
toys as it's a blast
especially if the tempo had them by um
uh Cognito if you want to wrap up let
him know if you got anything this
weekend and we will finalize this sucker
yeah man you already know Cognito on
twitter you know again salute to see him
even come and do man this is awesome
show actually do the interview before I
can talk they say you got anywhere to go
say no but you at look on Twitter you
know saying on our iron Lord podcast on
YouTube every Sunday is the Lord's Day
1:00 p.m. Eastern and we also now
starting the stream to twitch so all the
twitch guys here man if you follow our
Lord podcast we will be simultaneously
streaming and all make sure as well
check us out so this week we will have
some gaming royalty we'll have a hip hop
gamer and read infamy it will be on
we'll be talking about everything that
went down with the Xbox series ex nihilo
will talk about that we talked about the
latest rumors with Playstation 5 and
just general console talk you know and
also again really appreciate the support
and last but not least please the
support for our website Lords of gaming
that man dies man this you know it
trying to push towards gaming media
really helps us so thank you for all
support again you already know he hates
me but you already know the best day of
destiny Comcast though was never heard
of the last word and I promoted on iron
law podcast two minutes he'd be proud
proud but I really love this show a man
did you see the support did Chad
shoutout to CB grace community for
or pulling up show love man that's what
it's about it's about positivity
inclusiveness the exactly brother and
having fun we all love this game we love
this community with that and it's good
to see it's good to see that's what I
got I was like for me
Evon tests if you find the cheetah its
EB Ont is twitch Twitter YouTube all the
places and thank you guys very much
against EB it's been awesome so we will
wrap this thing up you guys remember for
the recordings we'll keep this thing
going and when we finish things this
thing all you guys are in the stream
right now I want to see me guys over to
Brian Marcus art he is streaming right
now working on his art if you guys have
seen him on Twitter he does some of the
cleanest s the art that you probably
have seen he streaming right now so we
will raid his channel so I want you guys
to take all of these pin foil at least
for this episode it has been episode 102
Thank You CB for joining us
may 8 the calendar will open up
potentially next week so thank you guys
very much
you guys have been awesome so have a
great orange I want to say thank you for
accommodating to the late time too I
know I worked during the day so thank
you guys for making oh hey Stuart lets
him sleep so it's totally fine so thank
you guys very much
ant for this episode it has been the
last